hello welcome to honest journal
commentaries the show where we're
talking about the show we made about the
mandalorian
um i am here with lon harris day long
good morning taco tuesday how's it going
yes
yeah there's taco awesome
uh if you haven't been here before one
more time uh we we talk about uh our
deep thought process behind ready ma's
trailer
we show you some deleted scenes uh we
respond to comments and questions
from viewers like you so keep them
coming in the chat if you got them and
then we tease you with next week's
honest trailer
um let's just jump right into talking
about the mandalorian
after we talk about the phantom five
trivia contest that you can sign up for
that will happen this friday with
questions provided by none other than
lon harris how hard are they launching
uh they're they're you know they build
so you get five
questions for a chance to win 150 bucks
uh
and then you know by by the time you get
to your fourth or fifth question
it's it's going to be a little you know
you're going to want to know your stuff
to start off they're they're pretty easy
it's like finish this quote
star blanks tours you know so it's like
yeah
we would accept that we would probably
max all right
uh okay the mandalorian this is my
favorite star wars thing
in a long time um i mean i really like
last jedi so probably post last jedi
and on this is this is my favorite story
hey you said it not me
um
i love this uh i love how it works uh
so well as a simple star wars story as a
a bare-bones star wars story uh where
you can bring
your curiosity and your enthusiasm to it
it's not overloading you with
lore and drama and and grand galactic
stakes and stuff like that
this is something i feel like we've kind
of lost in the
peak tv binge streaming era everything
now is so
like season arcs and everything is
thought of as like well this show is
just a 16-hour movie really like
everything is kind of trying for that
now especially genre stuff
and i it is you're absolutely right it's
like extremely refreshing
that this show is like throwback in that
way it does
i'm certainly not the first person to
come up with this but it really is
strongly reminiscent of like classic
western shows like like even like bounty
law the one from once upon a time in
hollywood
where it's like the gunslinger arrives
in a new town every week you know
aladdin from have gun will travel shows
up and it's like
these ranchers need his help and he gets
involved and
it's a you know it's a self-contained
story and then he moves on to the next
town and
and i've missed shows like that like
that's a thing that tv can do really
well
with a little bit of arc and a little
bit of carry over from episode to
episode
um sure it reminds me of a show we also
recently did not australia
avatar the last airbender where it's a
very good blend
of you know he's he's picking up friends
and allies and enemies along the way
and there are call backs and people show
back up that do reward
uh close watches but it's really like
adventure of the week it's like hey you
got to get this egg to make these jaws
happy
get that egg yeah i feel like we're kind
of now like we went
so deep into the like haunting of
bly manor world where everything is
super interconnected that
i think yeah where are like the witcher
2 kind of does this where it's like it's
got the
overarching plot lines where all of
these characters are going to meet up at
some point
but it's also monster of the week like
hey we got to go kill this dragon and
come with us
uh teddy fair and i know it's nice
you're talking about television but i
also think that this
is what hooked people in what was so
great about
a new hope like this movie the the first
star wars movie was just like a space
western
it was like you're a young ranch hand
you gotta go out and
and uh uh become a pilot and sit and
shoot down this giant spaceship like it
is a very simple bare-bones story
uh yeah and which is and that's always
been baked into
not just star wars but lucas and
spielberg's entire like original
early 80s vision for all of these
blockbusters it was you know
adventure serials like that's what
indiana jones 2 was sort of directly
inspired by
these old movies that you would like
these shorts and stuff you'd see before
the movie that were just like
here's a six minute episode and it's
part of the larger adventures of this
character but these are one-off little
mini adventures that you kind of pick up
and drop
you know one-offs yeah i mean the ironic
thing is though
as as bare bones as we're talking about
the storytelling and stuff like that
like this was
what a hundred million dollar series to
make this was
this was not like oh we're just going on
a back lot and like pointing some
plastic guns at each other
right and and hugely influential in in
the way a lot of these effects are going
to be done now i mean this was just in
the news this week that the robert
pattinson batman movie is going to use
that same like back projection
technique that they pioneered for the
mandalorian to make it look like yeah
he's on all these different planets and
all these different environments
while they can come in yeah well it is
if they're gonna use it
batman's going to space batman is yeah
he's joining the toretto gang
and he will be blasting into space in
this next adventure
i can't wait for the movie singularity
when you know we only go see one movie a
year but they're all
batman dom toretto and the mandalorian
in it f9
yeah f9 definitely space f10 definitely
time travel f11 multiverse i feel like
is inevitable so we will get he's gonna
they're going to the dc universe f11 is
just one long
you know like rap albums have that outro
track where it's just like shout outs
it's just that for the for everybody
that's ever appeared in a fantastic
fantasy in a fantastic furious movie
just all splitting off from each other
on different lanes on a highway
i am picturing like you know dom gets
the call from ludacris and it's like on
your left and then a bunch of portals
open and it's like
every car from every movie yeah
he's jumping in and yeah exactly bigfoot
the monster truck is gonna roll through
you know yeah been a long day without
you my friend
batmobile james bonds aston martin
swooping around come on uh um
oh god i'm gonna get crucified what's uh
what's mandalorian's ship called the
the the razor crest the razor crest okay
good different mandalorians
who knows study your ships folks there
you go
not the problematically named slave one
that's boba fett um
anyways we both like uh we both like
mandalorian there's not too much to talk
about except for what we say in the
honest trailer so let's roll it
after star wars was ruined forever
thanks to the monsters at disney
star wars will be unruined by an all-new
streaming series
made by the monsters at disney i'm
confused do they hate us or not
this is the way the mandalorian
anakin was supposed to bring balance
luke should have saved the day
and rey just ended up squatting at the
farm of her mentor's uncle
that he hated and couldn't wait to run
away from sorry sorry
not today gosh yeah i had to get into
this huh
couldn't couldn't just leave well enough
alone
it's why is she that why is she there
who did she know for longer a refresher
memory was it like it seemed like she
had a deeper connection with leia
than luke yeah off screen she definitely
took talked with leia more because
because she's directly training with
leia in between jedi and
how much time did she spend on uh luke's
bachelor island was it like
a month yeah i i i'm i'm pretty fuzzy on
on how long her stay was there i think
by this point
she definitely because she spent the
entire interim between movies with leia
training
you would have to like leia is her jedi
master like that's the jedi who trained
her
you would think that would be her
closest jedi bond
at this point it's just such a it
can't go back to alderaan like i get
that point but i also get that from a
screenwriting perspective what do you do
because there's no location
that we think of as being symbolically
the place that you would go to be close
to leia
right yeah it just it it hammers home
how
the star wars movies and i'll bring this
back to the mandalorian eventually
uh the the last star wars trilogy was
about star wars it wasn't about the
characters it was about
grappling with the the lore and the and
the past of the star wars movies
uh so it's like oh the star wars movies
began with that shot of luke on tatooine
so we got to end them
with well i guess the prequels whatever
we got to end it with that uh shot of
her on tatooine look at the same thing
even though it doesn't make sense for
the characters where's mandalorian there
he goes
uh they do let uh
they do let the characters you know
there's not much characterization
but it's all very clearly motivated
and simple characterization or they are
pushing the story forward
yeah i mean obviously one of the things
no matter how you feel about the sequel
trilogy good or bad like one of the
things that clearly was like a hang up
for them was they had this huge
narrative and it's like
how do we find things for each of our
characters to do within this narrative
like
you can always feel that like ah but
what's poe doing in this adventure like
oh well how do we use roads like it's
constantly this struggle in each movie
to like
find the place for everybody whereas
mandalorian by virtue of being a show
that is it's
the mandalorian it's his adventures it's
centered in that
experience and it's so yeah it's much
more successful
at unfolding as one person's story
it's just easier to do that when you
when you pick a hero and
stick with them like the the original
trilogy was luke's
with and i mean even the prequel trilogy
does it with
anakin like it's not quite as neat a
through line but it is his hair whereas
he's only a boy in the first one yeah
whereas rey
it starts off force awakens is pretty
strongly like this is rey's story but
then by last jedi
you start to muddle that a little and
then rise of skywalker it's sort of
yeah all bets are off we're we're
spending half our time at alien burning
man
all right keep going sorry sorry
not today episode nine now as our heroes
fall
one food truck enthusiast will rise
revitalize the franchise in his vr
garage
and keep the empire in business with
eight episodes of western riffs that got
the fan base all up in their feelings
over a muppet baby
kathleen kennedy more like crappily and
keen all
right this is a kathleen kennedy
drawing on her uh gremlins and gremlins
two production experiences yes
yes she's like we need a mogwai that's
what this thing's missing
wait hang on are you talking about a
little baby gremlin that's all cued and
wrapped up in swaddling clothes and his
entire role in the show is to look
adorable
you're crazy it's in the series
[Laughter]
yeah i love magic look people people
don't know nothing
the amount of amazing movies that
kathleen kennedy's name pops up on
is is mind-boggling she could she could
ruin star wars
and she would still have like an
impeccable filmography so
up on the game yeah no it's it's bananas
to go to that imdb like her and frank
marshall's names are on every movie i
loved from
ages like 7 to sixteen yeah uh
yeah i mean i don't i don't know like i
i a baby yoda
it's it's it it is adorable
it's fun it's very likable it does also
feel
so like purposeful and and marketing
speak and like what do we do like what's
going to be the toy that everybody has
to buy like
what can we scientifically designed to
be the most adorable thing in the world
that will grab
people and get their attention and it
and it worked you know like
but again like it's not out of character
for a star wars project
they've always tried to yeah bb-8 the
ewoks like they've always tried to
market
cuteness oh that is part of it yeah this
is like the refined crack rock of
cuteness like they put
the cutest droids and the cutest uh
aliens in a in in the pyrex and cooked
it down and then here it is
yeah yeah right this is this is like the
kathleen kennedy in her office like adam
sandler and uncut gems seeing the images
of this thing like oh my god
i think i'm gonna you finish that one
okay we won't say it
yeah you know the scene i'm talking
about here's one thing i think i put
this in my notes and it did not make it
into the honest trailer is anybody else
bothered by the fact that
the the child can't close his eyes all
the way
like when when he when it blinks its
eyes are like a third
open still well that's why it's it's
like
puppet disney come on it keeps the eyes
uh moist and like uh you know glistening
so that you can
uh so that it looks even cuter and your
protective instincts kick in even more
yeah anime dewyness
all right let's keep going suit up with
then jaren
aka mando which starts to sound like a
slur the more you hear it
hey mando hand over the child mando get
that plaster out of my face mando
uh guys that's their word are you sure
we can use it
after the prequels uh i'm sure this
exists but i don't know it like
what do aliens call humans in the star
wars universe or are we like terrans or
humi's or peep peeps well humans are
from a bunch of different
worlds right so that would make it weird
like it's not like humans have like a
home world in star wars
we're everywhere oh okay well you know
like because
there's humans on naboo but then there
were clearly also humans from tatooine
and alderaan and
so it wouldn't be like mandalorian is
like mandalore it's like a place
yeah so i that would make it that would
make it weird like i wouldn't
yeah i don't know why humans are
everywhere well
i won't make it weird but i'm sure
someone in the chat is uh is furiously
typing at me right now
but uh carry on i think it's humans just
from my history
we are starting to get answers come in
here langley is saying humans is what
they they
like they call them humans so we're
going off langley uh yes
yeah but it's not like a nickname that's
just like what our species is it's like
twilight or whatever but like yeah
yeah for my record there's no like mando
like you know like we
like what our dumb nickname is in the
galaxy
yeah all right um
i'm gonna go with humi just sounds kind
of insulting and fun
cracker probably keep going
i know after the prequels literally
ruined his childhood
follow this wandering bounty hunter on a
tale of redemption
in between a whole bunch of actual
wandering
[Music]
as he jets from exotics i think that the
wandering is actually important to have
in a uh in something like this and in
star wars in general and the uh
the new trilogy could have used more
wandering because like
if these are adventure stories like you
want to like take your time and like
soak in these places you don't want to
have to
like just show one shot of the
spacecraft landing on the new planet and
then bam bam bam like oh there's
oscar's exact girlfriend oh he's used to
sell spice oh attack attack run
yeah this is just some time to soak it
in it's the opposite of what it was
force jumping whatever they do with the
or or light speed skipping whatever they
do at the beginning of rise of skywalker
where it's like
eight worlds in like two seconds yeah
no i i i mean i was the one who sort of
picked up on this and made the note of
it and tracked all the times he's just
walking around but
i think tonally like aesthetically this
is also what kind of tips you off to
what kind of show it is like
it does make it feel like those classic
adventure shows where every episode
starts with
the lead character like riding his horse
into the new
town or whatever like it does kind of
establish like okay you're watching an
adventure show
he's in a new place he's got to get his
bearings and then find the spot where
the people are living you know like yeah
it just gives you a sense of place which
is like
i think important and if it's all just
going by so quickly like
somewhere uh in your lizard brain like
you don't really know where you are
when the story's happening so it doesn't
sink in as much it is also i think a
little bit
first season stuff that we are
establishing the world
in which the mandalorian is going to
take place like we'll probably come back
to a lot of these places
at some point so yeah you want to get to
know what navarro
is like because that's an important
location for the rest of the show
do you say navarro yeah that's the name
of the world where the
bounty hunter like that's where carl
named for dave navarro
yeah founder of the live moss philosophy
that's what i thought but it's actually
nevarro like n-e-v-a-r-r-o so not
exactly
how danny navarro spells it all right
well there's always season two
okay keep going go to planet navarro
everyone has nipples from exotic locales
to less exotic locales to a quick detour
to moss nostalgia to pick up delivery of
easter eggs
tuscan raiders but screw it
how fun is it to dick around in the star
wars universe without some sad kid in
their daddy issues killing the vibe man
everything will change when this long
not a gungan gunman
maybe he's a gungan meets the most
adorable macguffin of
all time the child okay you know what
we're not doing that he's a baby yoda
we're calling him baby yoda he's a magic
puppet
who can kill you with cuteness
[Music]
and if that doesn't work he can always
just kill you
no no stop but one thing is for certain
he's not nearly as precocious when they
reveal he's
actually a middle-aged man they said 50
years old
i'm on to you baby yoda you can talk
you're just some creepy boomer with a
diaper fetish aren't you
i can't believe i let my kid play with
you
yes we're aware it ages differently um
i still think that if you do the math of
like because we know how old yoda is
right isn't yoda like
900 100 yeah when 800 something
years old you are yeah but like the
proportion of like 50 out of 800
like if you convert that to human years
like yoda knows more than what's going
on
i mean they're obviously it's an
intelligent
species yoda the wise wisest master yoda
so you're telling me 50 years of lived
experience
is not enough for this kid to like start
making memories and understanding the
world around them like ah
i don't know if i buy it i don't have
stuff two jedi council members have come
from this beach because you also have i
don't know did you guys mention yaddle
no but we're aware
of course
yes you could consider us friends of
yattle um yeah i mean obviously this uh
uh this species remains a secret and
i think i read some story about like
lucas come came to the set and like
whispered
you know the secret of yoda species into
john favreau's ear or something like
that
so it's just gonna be a made-up word
right what's the secret
it's like actually just frogs like
what's it gonna be
i mean it's funny it's funny because
even in the um
even in the like behind the scenes stuff
for for empire uh
lucas is like it's like kermit the frog
and miss piggy had a kid or something
like that like he wasn't really
thinking big lore implications but
there's some secret
at the center of all of this only frank
oz knows the truth
yeah whatever man it works
from the same planet that the audrey ii
from little shop of horrors is from
that's
yeah but i i imagine that lucas
whispered that into whatever it was in a
favro's year and he's like cool cool
cool he's like i'm not using that
oh okay sure they're the wheels
or whatever the willis yeah whatever the
wills yeah
oh man um yeah any any more baby yoda
thoughts before we move on i mean that's
no i i think that i think they really
miss their like i know that
disney they're not crazy about baby yoda
is like that's what we're all calling it
like it's not it's not related to yoda
you guys i don't you know not
necessarily it's like well you had your
chance
like you you had a whole eight episode
series you could have given it a real
name
we're not all just gonna save the child
that's stupid i'm not gonna that's
stupid
so you didn't fill the void now we
filled it for you too late
it's baby yoda forever it's sort of i
mean because this is you know
as far as in canon it's a prequel it
does raise the question of like
where's where's baby yoda been during
um well this takes place before after
this is just a jedi jedi force awakens
and then how much time passes between
sorry i'm putting on the spot between
jedi and force awakens
jedi to force awakens has got to be what
like 15
50 years no however old kylo ren is and
kylo i think is you know in his 20s
because he you know obviously his entire
lifetime would have to take place
afterwards
um i'm i'm gonna look this up okay first
awakens is set 30 years after 30 years
so baby yoda will be 80 during force
awakens right and like kind of like a
like a teen like a moping teen you know
but where but where are they they're not
they don't seem to be helping
the resistance out you know it would be
incredible
and they would never do in a hundred
years
kill baby yoda in like the first episode
of season two
maybe baby yoda becomes snoke maybe
that's
the secret lucas whispered
but my god what uh what a game of
thrones like you're in uncharted
territory now of like first half of
season two it's like nope that's not
what this show's about yeah we're going
a different direction
oh god please yeah just some alien just
like eat something just marks it yes
what happened jason sedakis beats him to
death that's it chewbacca eats him but
you see the whole thing
yeah like he roasts him but this time he
doesn't back off after the other porgs
get upset
he just goes for it okay
anyways move on saddle up for brand new
star wars adventures
the likes of which you've never seen
before but don't freak out
look familiar stuff tatooine classic
stormtroopers
good breathe good in this tale of one
man's destiny to clear an extremely low
bar
be the best single dad in star wars
but this father-son pause i saw somebody
take take us to tess because
han wasn't a single dad but i feel like
they split up when kylo was
young no were they still together or was
it after kylo broke bad
yeah i think it was kylo when evil and
that drove them apart
you know like the trauma of losing their
son
okay well uh i did not see that you
didn't see that or i would have brought
that up well i mean he's a single dad
now yeah like they're not still together
so when he goes back to visit his son
he's in in his in his role as a single
dad he is a bad single dad from a
certain point of view
yeah all right keep it in we won't we
won't do it when we uh do the special
edition of this uh
trailer right we'll replace him with a
young job of the huff
keep going he was like a great dad to
stink
but this father-son won't travel alone
there's queel who finally gave a modern
update to talk to the hand
i have spoken i have spoken i have
spoken
tobias fume k's acting coach you take
this home
throw it in a pot add some broth a
potato baby you got a stew going
and cara dune the ex-rebel with less
range than the guy in the helmet
so we're gonna build a trap we're gonna
need to dig real deep
right here so when it steps in it drops
together they'll encounter scum villainy
and the best alternate dimension cast of
saturday night live
with horatio sans
oh man this would be so good amy sodaris
no offense to the current cast but i'd
rather watch this one yeah this is the
better one
jason sedakis and your host
tycho waititi sorry adam pally you
didn't make the caution
you mean my brain that was a joke
and yeah our requisite you know weekly
shout out to robert holtby for making
these incredible graphics on like
zero advanced warning like a day before
we're like it'd be funny if we made it
look like snl and then
boom he he puts this together yeah so
announce it just perfectly
i want him to host snl so bad now just
looking at that like
i i take itty as an ig droid yeah
ig 11 i think he is yeah god it'd be
better than
well i won't rant about snl uh right i
do want to see
uh mullany hosting the halloween episode
is gonna be fun
okay yeah i'll tune in for that but like
musical gets the strokes did you see
this
wow i feel like it's like 20 2005 again
um but i watched the first sketch of
like the last episode and it was
alec baldwin maya rudolph and jim carrey
yeah and it's like
none of these people are are on snl yeah
no
it was also uh i watched that sketch too
it was 11 minutes long like
that's not even a sketch anymore like
legally
you've expanded beyond the range of a
sketch at this point
yeah you're uh you're a children's
cartoon like come on yeah like nobody
needs to like monty python wasn't doing
11 minute sketches
back back away this is this way lies
madness but they need to beat for beat
repeat uh the uh the lines from the
debate but with funny voices
and then you watch the sketch and you're
like none that you guys didn't think
any of this could stand to be cut and
all of this needed to go in
full 11 minutes there wasn't any like
well we could probably lose this line
no no there's a lot of time to fill up
yeah it's a 90 minute you know i
i i have sympathy for having to make
that much stuff a week i mean we barely
put out you know a half hour a week of
what we do so get her to do a few more
songs some
killing all right we won't harp on snl
too long uh
let's let's keep going so strap in for a
show
that every level of star wars fan can
enjoy whether you're a new
who just wanted to know why baby yoda
was on your kid's christmas list but
stuck around because it reminded you of
the searchers
a casual fan who spent eight episodes
wondering why luke skywalker wasn't in
the boba fett show or
a hardcore nerd who needed validation
for keeping your toy collection mint in
box all these years
wait is that the imperial troop
transport
of my youth it's it's beautiful
that owes its success that line and
excuse me uh many other from this
trailer uh provided by
a friend of screen junkies and long time
friend of ours
of ours uh ken knapsock so bravo to ken
uh you know he's got that new inbox
what a what an invaluable connection
he's been during new mandalorian month
for all of our as you could tell by the
two of us being like how long is this
set
after june i wonder who are these people
what's the stormtrooper
uh without ken we'd be so long ken was
definitely our
yattle on this one and and really
anything star wars so
um please check out check out his star
wars book and
uh just uh he's a hell of a guy so shout
outs to ken
just check out kidnaps just check out
kidnap could check them out
tips to tale it's for your health check
it out
check it out uh all right keep playing
that owes its success to telling a
simple lean story
about an all-new family in the star wars
universe
and because it was a hit they're
probably about to weigh it down with a
bunch of lower crossovers and spin-offs
ah this is the way yeah pause just
briefly on that
it sent shivers down my spine although i
am really excited for season two it was
like the
disney earnings call like the most
recent one where uh
one of the bob's was talking about how
they're going to use mandalorian season
as a platform for spin-off characters
and it's like ah
man really like yeah like we're saying
the beauty of it was staying streamlined
and about
the mandalorian i feel like the the real
the warning shot across all of our bow
was uh rosario dawson joining as
ahsokatano because that definitely feels
like they're floating
what are we gonna do with this character
her own live action series maybe some
movies like
there's no way they're doing that just
as a one-off for mandalorian season two
it's
too big a casting maneuver it's too big
a character
so i feel like once that was introduced
like yeah now now we're going to use
this as the
sort of spine for all sorts of options
during this
during this time period like between
original
which is like it's good for business
it's not good for storytelling i'm sorry
like we like this because it's so
economical um because it's so
direct and clean and clear and the more
you weigh it down man the harder it is
to tell a good story
uh but we'll see we'll see if they can
you're always on a spectrum between
you know like complete standalone
storytelling and like the other end
which would be like
the tom cruise mummy where it's just the
whole movie exists to like
launch the dark universe and like barely
is its own story like
so it's all where you end up on that
spectrum yeah i hope they don't go full
mommy
uh can't go never go never go full mommy
oh my god
all right look at that it's the hand of
the creature from the black lagoon guys
someday someday i'm dr jekyll and mr
hyde
i'd like to tell you about a monster
dark universe project
in my lab over here okay bye never see
me again
i want to tell you about the monster
initiative
this is the way starring
dark helmet i'm 50.
baby you've got a rootley stew going mma
los poyos empiriales werner herzog
as himself i see nothing
but death and chaos
i would like to see the baby yes
i'm sorry sir you sounded like someone
else the babysitter clubs
shut your dumb mouth cause i have spoken
the outer skyrim
how do you like the maddox huh boba feed
let's make the baby do the magic hands
come on baby
do the magic hand thing that's not how
the magic hand thing works nerds of the
round table
and when my friends ask what fastball
song we're listening to
this is the way this is the way this is
the way this is the way
the way
so pause joestar basically dared us
to like leave that in and i said you
know what challenge accepted we're going
to make a reference too
yeah we're going to reference fastball
you know 90s
uh alt rock semi hit the way oh it was a
he was a monster hit
i don't know man was it yeah it was a
big song
i can't tell anymore i didn't love that
song he used to play it on guitar
you have to be kind of an old fart now
to remember it but yes it is
it's that big because i confused it with
um uh
one headlight uh the wall flowers
yeah so excuse me
wrong with you not a fastball fan um but
you know
it's it it kind of it kind of rocks it's
okay it's like
it chugs along it's got a it's a nice
mid-tempo uh
rock radio song it's fine but it's it's
fine
roads that they walked on were paid with
gold lawn um is there any more was that
the end of it i forget
there's still that was the end of uh
yeah we're just about to do the title
we're about to say rim job
yeah i was so excited i was so excited
for this such a good
rim job
and once again the galaxy is a mostly
mechanic bounty hunting and cantina
centric economy
no one's ever a real estate agent in
these things marketing somehow the star
wars universe remains dentist free
don't they have teeth there's your
spin-off show
i mean god wouldn't john favreau want to
make like a a food truck in the star
wars universe show like
like one time i would love for us to
spend a little bit of time with a
character who's not like a bounty hunter
an assassin like a mechanic i feel like
there's like five
jobs that every star wars character has
to pick from like you can't all be
scavengers somebody has to make the
things that you're later scavenging
you'd love to see like a uh like a fish
out of water in the star wars universe
like someone who gets wrapped up in this
world that but it's not yeah
that would be like all of my star wars
pitches would open like he's a
mild-mannered accountant
on bespin but then
one time i want to see like a mid level
like a middle management type
gets whisked off on a star wars
adventure okay it's gonna be all be
smugglers
i don't know man i played the uh the
star wars uh uh
online game and like your your
profession choices were like
smuggler bounty hunter jedi so
yeah like the jedi are so rare that even
still
most people it's just they don't even
exist you can't all be jedi
in a world where people don't even
believe they exist by the way
cara dune that there's no excuse for
that
the scene at her scene in the finale of
mandalorian where
the the head the gold the gold suit
mandalorian is like you gotta go find
the jedi and then karadu is like the
jedi
come on get off it that's not real like
you were in the rebellion
your leaders were jedi
yeah oh man they were just like in
charge you you don't wait you don't
believe
in luke skywalker like how you don't
have that option to not believe in luke
skywalker i'm sorry
i think that's in our deleted scenes
which we should play oh right now
kathleen kennedy more like crappy and
is forgiven starring
dad the bounty hunter man of steel
i know who i am i'm two dudes standing
in for the dude that's playing the title
dude
the golden child not
look who's force healing rebel rousey
how you do angel dusty
mm apex legend grandma fring
the sword of the frames what we do in
the cosmos
the tigernator can of steel
and mandalorian stairs
some good acting
power of that stare lone wolf and major
merchandising opportunity
amanda or dad problem child
oh there wasn't the uh other tag no
that's too bad yeah i know we
shot it and recorded it yeah basically
it was just what
was saying yeah it was just me ranting
this in a different format
that like come on you believe in the
jedi
you know i guess it's like you do
you she has to know they exist or all
these people have to exist but like
maybe they don't think that it's for
real
like it's like even so they would be
like oh that was just an elaborate hoax
that was pulled on all of it you
wouldn't be like i don't think they
exist
like right you would honestly i would
think cara dune would have more like the
it's real all of it like i would think
that would be her line there
because she's one of the few people that
would be in a position to actually know
yeah as a shock trooper or whatever
i have questions and uh uh you guys have
questions too
um brent trayer writes well this isn't a
question this is a correction
um if you're looking at it in human
terms it's about baby yoda the whole
species has an extended lifespan so
their
900 is our 90 which means their 50 is
basically
five so baby yoda not a five-year-old
i can say with some authority that that
five-year-olds can
speak and understand what's happening
around them but
even if their brain develops very slowly
and and they're eventually but they're
eventually going to have a very
powerful brain like a more powerful
brain than a human by
after 50 years of development you'd be
able to like talk
right no yeah all right all right um
something we didn't talk about adam
albert writes thoughts on gordon's
score controversial opinion i love it
more than the classic williams theme
there i said it
wow well i do like score yeah i i and it
does
it it is one of the elements that brings
you right back to like the classic tv
shows that it's kind of riffing on
while still feeling star wars-y which is
a tough balance to sort of
yeah it's hard to say which one's better
or worse
without bringing in context because i
think john williams score
is like just the best for the crescendo
of a film or or or the beginning middle
and end of a of the story whereas like
the the mandalorian score i could just
throw on like while i'm working
like you could just play that kind of
soundtrack to your day
i i mean i few pieces of film music and
it's hard to say because we don't hear
it in a vacuum like that's my whole life
that piece of music has been the star
wars score
but it's still like that opening when
you see star wars and the fanfare
like it's that's hard to top in the
annals of film music
yeah i'd probably give that the edge but
it is a great tv score and i really do
like the mandolin
yeah um a couple people asked variations
on this
uh wide veed and kayla morgan um how
worried are we that they're going to dip
their toes into the skywalker stories
are they going to keep the week-to-week
adventure format or is it gonna be
more of like a uh bigger uh bigger
connections to
star wars at whole yes i am worried and
i think that's where it's going but i do
believe in filonian and favro's ability
to maybe
walk that tightrope and pull it off just
because they've done it for many other
things many times before
but i i do think that especially with
like
you know so much pressure on disney plus
and so much pressure on this show is the
big breakout hit like they need to use
this or they want to use this
as the jumping off point for like all
the other projects they want to do
um and that can really dilute it dilute
what made it special so yes
afro february's already kind of paved
like
he already gave some interviews where
he's like it is gonna be more
interconnected in season two it is gonna
be more of a
overarching narrative and less but i'm
sure they'll still bake some of the
episodic stuff in there like at least a
few episodes will be
more one-off kind of adventures i'm not
as worried about skywalker stuff like i
feel like they know
better than to directly bring in like
main characters and sort of make this
what's happening with the skywalkers
during this period
i feel like instead it's going to be the
the
you know what happened to the remaining
jedi order during this period and like
the formation of the first order and the
resistance like
it's definitely going to start to set
more of the groundwork for the sequel
films yeah which is i agree kind of a
bummer
i i'd rather see it just be the
mandalorian story but
it's kind of inevitable when this show
can no longer dedicate an entire episode
to getting an
egg for some jawas then it's lost me um
when it's when there's a fan revolt like
how dare you stop the
uh the storyline that was chugging along
to go on this side quest where you like
go just run a random errand that to me
is the joy of the show for me so yeah i
can't do that anymore
there's definitely danger like you want
them to still have the freedom to do the
like terrence and philip movie
episode and not have to get right back
to cartman's
parentage reveals but like i yeah i
think that inevitably
we're not gonna have a choice and it's
gonna have to start to teeter in that
direction
yeah uh okay and one uh one last one
again from brent dreyer um
i know ming na wen was in the show but
was she in the trailer uh
no she was not she was yeah she was in
that boba fett scene right
yeah she's fennichand the the assassin
that they're hunting in that one episode
and then yes the
boba fett shot he's walking up to where
she is
so the presumption is she's still alive
she's in play
she'll be back for for season two in
some context
and we know tamara morrison is gonna be
in season two as boba fett so that's
going to pay off
some wow spoilers um well yeah apologies
for
cast that's no it is known come on it is
known
apologies she was not included but she
did an admiral
admirable job write your own ming na
joke below and you gave her a shout out
in the live action mulan trailer and
she's only in that movie for a second so
get off come on uh okay that about wraps
it up
um i really enjoyed talking about this
show
re-watching it doing this trailer uh and
i hope i feel the same way
when we meet here in you know six months
and talk about the mandalorian season
two or however long it takes us
um you guys thanks for watching like and
subscribe if you haven't
uh that's always nice and uh come back
next week where we will be talking about
something
let's say very loosely u.s election
themed
very loosely but
you'll see the connection when you come
back next week uh right here
same time same place for australia
commentaries thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you